هذا يعني بانه ما ذكره المتحدث الرسمي لك
الكلام لان اللي اعتبر قبل ايام انه على
اوكرانيا قبل كل شيء ان تقر بان لوكانس
كودونسكو وزباروجيا وخرسون مناطق تنتمي
الى روسيا هذا موضوع غير قابل للنقاش غير
قابل ان يكون على طاوله مفاوضات بين
الطرفين برايد
في ال 30 ثانيه
ان كان يخسر المعركه والحربه اوكرانيا
بدءا من نهايتها اغسطس الاشهر الاخيره
الاربعه من 20 الشنار الاوكرانيون عمليات
هجوم مضاد ودفعوها الى مناطقانس وشاهدنا
الاخرين يدفعون الجيش الروسيه خارجه من
الغريبي جدا
حقيقيه على
ارض شهر بعد شهر اليس يعني حتى لو في بعض
المناطق لم تستطع تحقيق ما ارادته فيها
ليس من شان هذا ان يمهد الطريق لمفاوضات
من نوع ما او ربما لاحقا فرض امر واقع
يجبر زلانسيك على التفاوض
التي اسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي بعد 24 من
فبراير 20 22 22
الديسكو
ان ركبت الطور والامور اعتقد من هنالك
امكانيه جيده من الالكترونيه سوف يستمرون
بدفع جيش الروسي الى الوراء لان الجيش
الروسي قياده ضعيفه والقوات الروسيه غير
متحفزه ولديه
جدا
الى روسيا
فاتوقعوا من الاخرانيه
همم روسي
هي الضحيه في هذه الحرب اوكرانيه تستحق
دعم الغرب
وتستحق دعم العالم اجمع